These next clips are an absolute pleasure
to watch Donald Trump's kooky lawyer, Rudy
Giuliani, has turned on Donald Trump's kooky
lawyer, Sydney Powell.
Now, there are about four or five layers of
hilarity here.
The first layer of hilarity is that weeks
ago when Sydney Powell appeared to go crazy
at these events at which she appeared with
Rudy Giuliani claiming Hugo Chavez and Venezuela,
Cuba antifa were all involved in stealing
the election of George Soros to a Trump put
out a statement saying, this woman has no
involvement with us, period.
She's working by herself.
And then Rudy Giuliani went just as bonkers
himself, telling us about as crazy of a story
about what happened with the election.
Then Trump had Sydney Powell at the Oval Office
on Friday, and she was the one pushing Trump
to do absolutely ridiculous things like trying
to forcibly seize voting machines.
And then the latest just incredible event
in this series of of embarrassment is that
Rudy Giuliani appeared yesterday on Sean Spicers
Newsmax program and appeared to turn on Sydney
Powell.
Now, before we even get to that Sean Spicers
Newsmax program.
Yes, Sean Spicer, Donald Trump's former White
House press secretary, has a show on Newsmax.
That alone is hilarious.
But I can't even focus on that because we
have to get to what Rudy says here.
Is Rudy insinuating that Sydney Powell's approach
is outside of rationality, common sense and
the law?
Take a look.
Right.
And I know some of these folks have picked
her up going in and out of the West Wing,
but is she, to the best of your knowledge,
meeting with the president about some of these
strategic moves to either impounds or seize
voting machines or become a special counsel
to investigate fraud?
Well, look, it's my responsibility as the
president's lawyer, along with Jenna and some
of the others, we're going to be extremely
aggressive.
We're going to fight for our client as hard
as we can.
But we're also going to do it within the bounds
of rationality, common sense and the law.
And it can be done.
There's no reason to go beyond anything that
there was.
This election was a theft.
It can be proven.
I can tell you one simple thing that would
prove it, make the American people feel really
good.
Five or six of these crooked governors could
let us have access to the machines.
What's really just Kafkaesque here is that
Rudy Giuliani is no voice of reason.
Rudy Giuliani is pursuing ideas that are almost
as nutty as what he's saying Sydney Powell
is going too far with, but he says she's going
too far and she's not working with us.
Well, Rudy, you're doing things that are essentially
is bonkers as what she's doing here is Rudy
in plain English saying Sydney Powell is on
her own.
Rudy, by the way, appears to be doing the
interview from a restaurant.
It sounds like there's silverware clanking
in the background.
But I want to bring you back to these reports
that in the Oval Office, Sydney Powell, who
had been part of your legal team until she
was dismissed, has been there at least three,
potentially four times.
So there's a rumor that she's trying to become
or people are advocating that she be appointed
special counsel and that voting machines be
seen.
Can you tell us what's happening in the Oval
Office and what a role will be?
Let me say definitively, Sydney Powell is
not part of our legal team.
She hasn't been for five weeks.
She is not a special counsel for the president.
She does not speak for the president, nor
does she speak for the administration.
She speaks for itself.
And she's a fine woman, a fine lawyer.
But whatever she is talking about, it's her
own opinions.
I'm not responsible for them.
The president isn't, nor is anybody else on
our legal team.
So now Rudy is both distancing himself from
Sydney Powell, but at the same time not.
And what I mean by that is he says she's not
part of the legal team.
Well, we knew that.
We knew Trump.
Trump claimed that weeks ago.
Rudy says she's not special counsel.
Well, we know that right now she's not special
counsel.
The story is Trump is thinking about making
her special counsel.
Rudy says she doesn't speak for the president.
No one claimed she did.
She's not his press secretary.
And Rudy says she doesn't speak for the Trump
administration.
Again, nobody has claimed that.
So.
Notice how Rudy distances while not actually
refuting the assertions which include Sydney
Powell was at the Oval Office on Friday.
Sydney Powell met with Trump.
Sydney Powell suggested a seizure of voting
machines, and Trump is thinking about appointing
her special counsel.
Rudy doesn't debunk any of that.
He just generally distances.
And then lastly, and this is so funny, here's
Rudy on Newsmax with Sean Spicer now attacking
Fox News, saying Fox News won't let him on
anymore to make his voter fraud claims.
I can't get on I can't get on ABC, NBC, CBS
could have gone to Fox anymore.
I say the word fraud.
I'm thrown off the network.
I'm sorry there was fraud.
I'm telling the truth.
And they're lying completely indistinguishable
from parody at this point.
Very strange times that we live in.
I'm shocked daily that this is real life.
And speaking of Fox News, let's talk about
what happened there